have you heard
due to higher call volume
anytime recently
nobody wants to be on hold for 15
minutes only to realize nothing can be
done
since the pandemic digital banking has
increased from 49 to 67
redefining what a banking experience
really is
banks are well aware that customers may
contact them through different channels
but from a customer's viewpoint it's not
about the channels it's about their
relationship with the bank the customer
would love an agent just to know the
context of their inquiry without being
subject to 20 questions 81 of
organizations compete on the basis of
customer experience
fortunately banks already have most of
the assets and technology in-house to
begin delivering experiences customers
really enjoy a major overhaul isn't
necessary banks can get a lot of mileage
out of straightforward organizational
and technology tweaks i'll lay out three
key areas that can help
optimizing and scaling responsiveness
leveraging data and trusting ai
let's start with optimizing and scaling
responsiveness
so you've been on hold for 15 minutes
why
at this point most banks simply don't
know and that's because they may not
have the information they need to fully
understand the context of the customer's
inquiry
most banks have simple chat bots
designed for simple questions or
identifying keywords within a specific
context but a virtual agent with
conversational ai can handle a lot more
than that
banks should be asking questions like do
we have channel integrations so the
conversation can flow from in-app to web
to a phone call with the customer
do we have sentiment analysis to pick up
on frustrations happiness or emotions is
historical conversational data easily
accessible to provide context from the
previous interactions
the objective is to really hear a
customer and understand if it's a
trivial task or a question that can be
automatically addressed
or
it's necessary to route the customer to
the proper associate
this gets the customer to the right
answer or to the right person in a much
shorter amount of time now that your
customer has reached the right agent be
sure the agent is armed with the
information they need
on this channel we've discussed a data
fabric a few times so if you haven't
heard about it check out the link above
a data fabric architecture consolidates
disparate data sources allowing
enterprises to access and leverage all
data
it doesn't matter to a customer that the
data they needed to open a new credit
card or apply for a new car loan aren't
in the same place they view it as a
single experience it's just like a
friendship the relationship is built on
all interactions
to a bank though this relationship is
complex
critical customer behavior information
and records are spread across unique
databases a data fabric provides the
ability to connect and aggregate that
data without moving it it also helps
with regulatory concerns of your
business applications with governance
and privacy controls
so instead of your agents calling and
leading with questions they will already
know for example the caller has a
half-completed loan application recently
changed their address and increased
their spending 20 year-over-year it
gives the agent the relationship context
today's customers expect now that your
customer is speaking to a well-informed
agent now is the opportunity to really
wow them
business analysts data science teams and
application developers are using ai to
provide things like life event
predictive models
automate loan application processing or
prevent payment frauds but ai only works
if you and your customers trust its
recommendations that's why 77 percent of
global it professionals agree ensuring
trust within their ai is critical to its
adoption so trustworthy ai is built on
five pillars fairness robustness privacy
explainability and transparency so for
example a real wow factor would be an ai
model notifying the call center agent
while on the phone that the customer is
pre-approved for a credit card with more
benefits than what they originally
called in for with a trusted ai model
that can remove biases is regulatory
compliant and can explain its results
banks can quickly turn an ordinary
customer interaction into one that is
truly enjoyable the reliance on digital
banking experiences presents a unique
opportunity they can boost their
responsiveness to client inquiries build
ai models that better understand and
predict client expectations all based on
data they already have
it can replace a stressful
friction-filled task for agents and
customers alike with an experience that
can really wow them to see upcoming
videos on more ways to transform your
business and learn more about technology
please like and subscribe